Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Katharine Dahn. Ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anäßige Sprache führen.
Können Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne in der Beschwerden sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Aufwürfe beschwerden, sprechen Sie ganz schnell eine Frage an sich stellen Sie sich damit ein.
Ja, ich habe da gleich eine Anmerkung. Können Sie bitte ein bisschen langsamer sprechen?
Ja, natürlich. Ja, klar.
Hallo.
Unsere Verbindung ist schlecht, oder?
Ja, irgendwie stehen Sie jetzt, schlimmste Fall.
Heißt du Sie?
Ich heiße Magdalena.
Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Okay. Frau Schmidt.
Ja, hier herz ich Sie.
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
Okay.
Und wann genau ist sie geworden?
Am 11, 6, 66 Meter.
Wie schwer sehst du Frau Schmidt?
Na ich wissen 79 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
1,68 m, ja.
Frau Schimmit, was führt Sie zu uns?
Was für Beschwerde haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, also mein rechter Arm macht mir Sorgen.
Wissen Sie, der ist seit einigen Tagen geschwollen
und das wird immer mehr.
Und der tut mir auch weh.
Und der Arm ist eigentlich über die ganze Länge,
und das ist der Rot.
Und ist auch ein bisschen heiß, fühlt er sich an.
Und ich habe so ein Spannungsgefühl da drin.
Und das fühlt sich irgendwie gar nicht gut.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, ich kann den gar nicht richtig krumm machen.
Das gibt so einen Widerstand.
Und ja, das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen unheimlich.
Deswegen bin ich hier direkt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, das ist gut, dass Sie hier hergekommen sind.
Rechter Arm, habe Sie Schmerzen?
Und hatten Sie irgendwelche Verletzungen oder Unfall?
Nein, Unfall oder Verletzung ist mir nicht,
habe ich nicht gehabt, ne?
Okay, strahlen Sie Schmerzen in andere Körperfeile aus?
Ausdrehen, tut das nicht, nee,
das ist auf den Arm bestrengt da, wo es so dick und beschwollen ist.
Okay, dick und beschwollen.
Leute, hauptsächlich haben Sie gehabt.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen,
oder haben Sie Schmerzen in Arm?
Ja, also, das tut auch weh.
Das ist so ein Druckgefühl, so ein Spannungsgefühl.
Die Schmerzen sind vielleicht gar nicht mal so das Schlimmste.
Es ist mehr so dieses Gefühl, dass das so übermäßig dick ist.
Okay, okay, genau.
Und ein bisschen blöd geworden.
Okay, haben Sie Sekken bis...
Sorry, das ist gerade so laut im Hintergrund.
So, jetzt, ja.
Haben Sie Sekken bis gehabt?
Sekken bis... Nein.
Nein, okay.
Hatten Sie sich häufig im Badgebiet auf?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Also, ich habe schon ewig lange nichts mehr mit Sekken zu tun gehabt.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Oder können Sie diese Schmerzen auch bei einer Schmerzfeller beschreiben?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Druckgefühl haben
und ein bisschen dicker geworden, die Arme.
Und auch ein bisschen auch, haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen auch bei einer Schmerzfeller beschreiben?
Wobei, von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr lecker,
sehr, sehr starker Schmerz meint?
Ja, vielleicht bei 6 oder so.
Also, das tut schon ordentlich weh.
Und insbesondere, wenn ich versuche, das zu bewegen.
Und der Arm fühlt sich einfach auch schwer an.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Das ist jetzt seit einigen Tagen.
Und, ja, das ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht besser geworden.
Okay, genau.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam?
Das ist ziemlich plötzlich aufgetreten.
Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sieb die Schmerzen drückend oder ziehend oder brennend beschreiben?
Brennt ist das nicht.
Und stechend ist es auch nicht.
Es ist eher drückend.
Drückend.
Und wie kann man das noch beschreiben?
Drückend ziehend vielleicht so.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lehnt, oder versteht?
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt mit den Armen viel bewege, das ist schlecht.
Das ist unangenehm.
Und auch wenn ich ihn runterhängen lasse.
Das bequemst du eigentlich immer, wenn ich ihn so ein bisschen festhalte
mit der anderen Hand, dann kann ich es am besten aushalten eigentlich.
Okay.
Ja, können Sie ein leichtes Gegenstände anheben?
Zum Beispiel, Sie haben gesehen, was ich mehr zum Parfum habe.
Wenn Sie bewegen.
Ja, also, was gar nicht.
Aber ich bin jetzt eigentlich in diesen Tagen so ein bisschen zum Linkshänder mutiert.
Weil ich den rechten Arm schon auch überwiegend schon, weil es nicht angenehm ist.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Taupaitskippeln oder Grieben, Tameisenlaufen?
Sowas habe ich nicht bemerkt, ne?
Okay.
Kraftlosigkeit.
Leiden Sie unter Kraftlosigkeit?
Ja, also ich benutze den Arm halt nicht.
Aber ich glaube so richtig, richtig dool, kraftlos ist er nicht.
Nein, er ist nur durch die Schellung eingeschränkt.
Okay.
Können Sie diese Haut, die Zwerbverbung, Sie habe gesagt,
das ist ein bisschen roter geworden, die Haut.
Ja, und sie glänzt auch so.
Bitte?
Sie haben die Beläge auch rot geworden.
Und können Sie diese Hautverbung beschreiben?
Die Grenzwertigkeit, diese Hautverteilung, ist grenzwertig, oder?
Was meinen Sie mit grenzwertig?
Meinen Sie scharf begrenzt, oder wie?
Dass es eine Stelle ist, wo es rot ist, oder was?
Sind die diese betroffene Bereiche grenzwertig, oder?
Die Hautverfärben.
Also der ganze Arm ist geschollen und es ist insbesondere im Unter-
und im Oberarm und im Gelenkbereich, ist das alles rot verfärbt.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie Friedmann?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, aber das könnte schon sein, aber ein bisschen warmer.
Jetzt schwitzt man sowieso, weil es draußen so warm ist.
Aber ich habe nicht Temperatur gemessen.
Okay, aber fühle Sie sich auch nicht fügig?
Nein, so richtig führe ich mich nicht nahm.
Gut.
Wussten Sie?
Wussten?
Nee.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot oder Hassrasen,
Hassstolpe und Hassglocken?
Nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Nur der Arm tut mir eigentlich doll weh.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Lampknoten in anderen Bereichen?
Oder in anderen Bereichen?
Dass die Lymphknoten geschwollen sind.
Ja, also da muss ich jetzt dazu sagen, dass ich vor vielen,
vielen Jahren eine Brustreparation hatte.
Und da sind natürlich Lymphknoten entfernt worden.
Aber jetzt habe ich das nicht festgestellt,
dass da irgendetwas geschwollen ist.
Okay, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Atemduschbau oder Verstruckung?
Nein, zur Daumen ist ganz normal.
Ja, das ist gut.
Hab es sich meistens beim Wasser lassen,
oder mit dem Stuhlgang, oder so etwas?
Nee, nee.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter Blähungen oder das Wortbrennen oder Bläschen?
Nein, auch zur Daumen ist alles normal.
Und ich habe auch keine Magenprobleme oder so etwas.
Okay, das ist gut.
Wie ist Ihr Apfekt?
Mein Apetit.
Ja.
Meistens ist es sehr gut, würde ich nur sagen.
Okay.
Habt ihr in der letzten Zeit umgehört oder ab oder zugenommen?
Ja, ein bisschen habe ich zugenommen.
Ich habe ein bisschen zu gut gegessen, ja.
Okay, wie viel Kilogramm habe ich dazu genommen?
Ein, zwei Kilo in den letzten sechs Wochen.
Sechs Wochen, okay.
Okay, können Sie gut schlafen wegen der Schmerz?
Ja, also jetzt wegen den letzten Tagen habe ich tatsächlich nicht so gut geschlafen,
weil ich das beim Liegen irgendwo gut haben konnte.
Ich habe dann zwischendurch so ein kleines Kissen gehabt,
wo ich den Arm drauf gelegt habe, dann ging das.
Aber so gut wie sonst habe ich nicht geschlafen.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an eine wichtige Vorerkrankung,
von denen ich das Wort habe, zum Beispiel an einer Blutdruck-Krankheit,
Blutdruck-Krankheit oder?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, klar.
Ja.
Und ich habe auch ein bisschen erhöhte Blutvertwerte.
Und ja, eigentlich das Wichtigste ist,
dass ich eben vor 14 Jahren diese Brustoperation hatte wegen Brustkrebs.
Genau.
Aber sind Sie jetzt klatschfrei, oder?
Bitte?
Sie ist klatschfrei?
Ja, also das ist eigentlich alles im Guten operiert.
Und ich habe dann keine Nachbehandlung bekommen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und wegen Arterielle, ich glaube,
nehmen Sie welche Medikamente?
Ja, ich nehme Konko 5.
Ja, Konko 5.
Eine morgens.
Genau.
Und dann nehme ich die Ovan 160, auch eine morgens.
160, ja.
Ovan.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen diese erhöhte Blutvertwerte?
Dann nehme ich eigentlich gar nichts.
Weil man eigentlich sagt, es ist kaum zu beeinflussen.
Und auch vor einer Ernährung her mache ich jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders
kolliserienfrei.
Man sagt, das gibt es halt, dass die ein bisschen erhöht sind.
Ja, okay, können wir auch unsere Lebensweise auch ein bisschen
ein bisschen sportreiben.
Ja, wobei mit dem Sport ist das so eine Sache.
Ich habe vor einem Jahr eine Hüft-Tab bekommen auf der rechten
Seite.
Und insofern war ich also mit dem Sport,
musste ich ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Ich wollte ein bisschen Reha-Sport machen.
Aber ansonsten kann ich schon ein bisschen etwas tun.
Ja.
Wann haben Sie diese Hüft-Tab total endokrotisiert?
Vor einem Jahr war das.
Vor einem Jahr, okay.
Wegen Konkertlose, ja.
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Nein, ich habe keine allergischen.
Und Sie sind bei Ihnen in die gesamte Gut-Reit-Ligkeit weg?
Nein, ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Meinen Sie es beim Essen oder bei Medikamenten?
Das kann eigentlich alles vertragen.
Das ist gut.
Sie sind gegen etwas und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also hin und wieder mein Glas Wein,
oder wenn es jetzt so warm ist, auch mein Glas Bier.
Aber also jetzt nicht viel.
Okay, das ist gut.
Natürlich ist es ein Teil der Zeit.
Ein paar Wein oder Bier manchmal.
Und trinken Sie Rauch?
Nein, geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Okay, das ist gut.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese nächste, meine nächste Frage nicht dazu,
das ist eine medisische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Drogen nehmen?
Drogen? Ich? Nein, nein, nein, keine Drogen.
Frau Schiedig, wegen dieser Typ-5-Gelenk-Operation
können Sie nicht gut Sport treiben.
Ja? Ja, momentan.
Und ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Impfstattus fragen.
Wie ist die Impfstattus?
Gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft, ja, dreimal.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und andere Grutifunken haben Sie erhatten?
Ja, also alles, was man so dringend braucht,
habe ich im Laufe der Jahre bekommen, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Im Ausland war ich nicht, nein.
Okay, das ist schön.
Haben Sie die grüßige Bestärkung,
oder welche Messulation ist die Plus?
Oder haben Sie die Messulation?
Ja, das läuft jetzt so langsam aus, ne?
Also da, also die letzte, die letzte Bregeblutung
liegt schon ein bisschen zurück.
Okay, die letzte, letzte Bregeblutung ist ein bisschen zurück.
Ja, das ist mit 52 oder so gewesen.
Ja, 42.
Okay.
Und vor vier Jahren?
Vor vier Jahren, aber jetzt haben Sie keine Blutung.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie nicht lang sind?
Nein, ganz sicher nicht.
Okay.
Raus schmiert, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familiengeschichte
etwas fragen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Familien-Exkrankungen in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich mich so sollte?
Ja, also mein Vater ist sehr früh an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Und mein Bruder hatte tatsächlich auch vor vier Jahren
einen Herzinfarkt, der hat den aber überstanden.
Aber also da gibt es irgendwie eine Belastung.
Und meine Mutter hatte jetzt auch schon vor langer Zeit
eine Hüftgelenkoperation.
Und die hat auch ein bisschen Bluthochdruck,
genau so wie ich.
Und ich habe auch eine Schwester, die hatte vor einem Jahr
auch einen Brustkrebs.
Und ist da operativ behandelt worden.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt ist sie welche Werte fallen?
Und jetzt geht ihr so weit gut, ja.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und Ihr Vater auch habe eine Herzinfarkt, oder?
Ja, der ist früh an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay.
Und mit wem, ohne Sie zusammen?
Ich lebe mit meinem Mann und ein Sohn ist noch im Haus
und die beiden sind schon ausgezogen.
Okay.
Und sieht die Kinder gesund?
Meine Kinder sind alle gesund, ja.
Was machen Sie als Begrifflich?
Ich arbeite im Reisebüro, ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraum.
Frau Schmidt, können Sie wiederholen?
Ich habe ja nicht gut gehört.
Ja, Ihr Bild hat auch wieder gestanden.
Ich arbeite im Reisebüro, ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraum.
Ja, ich habe das gemerkt.
Ich arbeite in einem Reisebüro, ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraum.
Das ist die Bürosbezeichnung.
Sind Sie zufrieden auf der Arbeit?
Mit der Arbeit.
Ja, jetzt geht es ja wieder los.
Wir hatten blöde Jahre, wir hatten keine Ahnung,
wir hatten keine Ahnung, wir hatten keine Ahnung,
wurde geschwollen sind.
Der rechte Arm ist geschwollen.
Ein bisschen lotter Verwerbung haben sie auch bemerkt und ein halb Hitzegelfel,
Verbengefel haben sie auch an diesem betroffenen Bereich bemerkt.
Die Schmerzen sind drückend unziehend und auf eines Schmerzskollers haben sie bei 6 angeordnet.
Die Schmerzen sind bemerkungsabhängig und können sich nicht gut bemerken wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Ein Aufwarten in einem Wartgebiet haben sie verneint.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Fährt Ihnen noch etwas ein, das wichtig sein könnte?
Nein, mehr könnte ich nicht sagen.
Das war das, was ich so anbestärbt habe.
Okay, und Verletzungen oder eine Unfall haben Sie auch vermeint?
Genau.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Manche Therapie-Massnahmen werde ich rufgeführt.
Wie lange wird das jetzt dauern?
Das müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Nach dieser körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich ein Leutgenbild für diese Werte anborden.
Mit dem Oberarzt werde ich sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprächung komme ich zu Ihnen zurück.
Ich sage Ihnen, was für Zunächst.
Okay, dann warte ich jetzt.
Danke schön.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Hatten Sie schon einmal das Früher?
Nein, das hatte ich noch nie.
Sie haben gesagt, Brust entfernen.
Eine Brust oder beide Brust entfernen.
Rechte Brust ist operiert worden.
Sie haben gesagt, die Brust entfernen.
Welche Brust entfernen?
Eine Epikris-Bericht.
Also die Axiläon-Lymphnoten sind entfernt worden.
Rechte, rechte.
Welche Diagnose haben Sie gemacht?
Mamakazinom.
Also Brust-Krips.
Wobei welcher Typ oder so weiß ich jetzt natürlich nicht.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe auch eine.
Wenn Sie auf die Schwellung eindrucken, bleibt eine Delle?
Nein, das geht eigentlich ziemlich schnell wieder zurück.
Noch eine Frage.
Wie handelt Ihre Nachname mit T oder D?
Mit 2 T.
Ich habe D geschrieben.
Bitte?
Das habe ich D geschrieben.
Diese Frau Schmidt hat 2 T.
Haben Sie irgendein Medikament eingenommen gegen die Dichmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, ich habe gar nichts genommen.
Wie immer gedacht habe, es geht alles wieder weg, was von alleine gekommen ist.
Aber es passiert nicht immer.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ja, eine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Wunde in den betroffenen Arm bemerkt?
Bemerkt habe ich die nicht.
Was aber nicht aussieht, dass da vielleicht auch eine sein könnte.
Können Sie anfangen als Geschenk, Mehmet?
Ja, genau.
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Berestin.
Frau Berestin, hätten Sie gut gesagt für mich?
Ja, klar.
Frau Martellina Schmidt, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Sie ist 46 Jahre alt und 79 kg schwer und 1,68 m groß.
Frau Martellina Schmidt hat sich heute bei uns seit 3 Tagen bestehender angeschwollene Arme
und drückende, ziehende Schmerzen an diesem Arm vorgestattet.
Welche Arme ist das vorhin?
Rechtenarme, angeschwollene Rechtenarme.
Die Schmerzen seien für lustig aufgetreten und die beschwerden auch.
Und die Schmerzen seien bewegungsabhängig.
Und der Patient klagte über eine Wärmegefühl an diesem betroffenen Bereich.
Und lot der Verwaltung und Spannungsgefühl.
Und auch die Patienten haben bemerkt, dass hier ein bisschen dicker geworden ist.
Und der Patient klagte die Patienten über eine 2 kg Gewitzsunahme in den nächsten 6 Monaten.
Und wegen dieser Schmerzen und Beschwerden leide der Patient die Patienten unter einer Insomnia.
Und die war der Begegnung sei unauffällig bis auf oben genannte Symptome.
Und die Patienten seien nicht traurig und triggte gelegen Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Und die Vorgeschichte ergaus sich eine Art Lehtertonie.
Dagegen nehmen die Patienten eine Konkurrenzmegra, morgens einmal am Tag ein.
Und die waren 160 mg morgens einmal am Tag ein.
Und die Patienten leiden an einer Cholesterol-Lömmi und die nicht medikamentbehandlung bedürftig ist.
Und die Patienten seien vor einem Jahr wegen einer Kosatrose eine total endoprofese durchgekippt worden.
Und die Patienten seien vorstellig gelegt und die Reise ins Ausland wurde verneint.
Die Frage nach Reise ist, ob die Reise in der letzten Zeit wurde verneint.
Und die Messeration beschwerden sei unauffällig oder die Frauen an einer Säber sei unauffällig.
Die Patienten seien verheiratet und leben mit ihrem Mann und mit einem Sohn zusammen.
Ich habe drei Kinder, ein Sohn und zwei Töchter, die alle gesund sind.
Der Familiengeschichte fand sich eine Biokartnipartis bei den Taten, die gestorben sei.
Der gestorben ist.
Der Bruder sei, habe eine Leide an einer Biokartnipartis und der noch lebe.
Die Mutter habe eine total endoprofese gehabt und Leide an einer Arzt-Löhm-Hypertone.
Die Schwester hatte eine Operation wegen Brust-Operation vor einem Jahr.
Und die Patienten arbeiten in einer Reisebüro als Reiseverkehr auf dem Raum.
Und die Patienten seien zufrieden bei der Arbeit.
Die anonystischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Abstehe an diesem Rechtebereich.
Als die Transgender-Unglösung kam, eine Borreliose und eine Peripherik,
Peripherikartilettverschlussverrankheit an diesem Bereich.
Das ist der selten Nummer, der könnte erst auf sein.
Lenf ödämme und Lenf ödämme in Betrat.
Was ist denn noch ziemlich naheliegend?
Als die Transgender-Unglose.
Lenf ödämme und Borreliose.
Borreliose?
Ja.
Dicker geschwollener Arm der Schmerzen macht.
Wenn das am Bein wäre, was würden Sie dann denken?
Ja, tief während Rombose können wir denken.
Ja, kann man auch am Arm kriegen.
Ja, oder eine Flebitis, ne?
Ja, Flebitis.
Wie gehen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch vor?
Diagnostisch würde ich ein paar diagnostische Bildgewendes verfahren.
Was machen Sie erst mal? Machen Sie doch eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Genau, körperliche Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Parästhesie und Hypoesthesie.
Ich werde die Parästhesie und Hypoesthesie anschauen und beurteilen.
Und für die Kraftlosigkeit werde ich diese an diesem Bereich anschauen.
Und Lähmungserscheinungen oder neurologische Gründen werde ich beurteilen.
Und diese Hautverfärbung werde ich lokalisieren.
Und ob das Granz fertig oder scharf abgegrenzt ist.
Ja, scharf abgegrenzt, das ist der Fachgegriff.
Scharf abgegrenzt, der Rötung.
Und wonach gucken Sie noch?
Ja, und ob er ein Zeckenbiss hat?
Zeckenbiss oder etwas anderes?
Ja, etwas anderes, z.B. Borreliose.
Nein, bei Zeckenbiss ist ja Borreliose.
Wenn Sie mal vom Insektenstich weggehen, was könnte denn sonst noch sein?
Ja, die Narben werde ich beurteilen.
Die Narben von der Narben.
Aber generell muss man doch gucken, ob da irgendeine Hautlision ist.
Egal ob durch Zeckenbiss oder durch sonst irgendwas.
Die kann sich ja auch irgendwie gescheuert, gestoßen oder sonst was haben,
ohne das zu merken und kann eine kleine Runde sich zugezogen haben.
Gut, also danach würde man gucken, was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labortechnisch werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Ein gutes Werte würde ich anschauen.
Und andere Blutfettwerte auch würde ich anschauen.
Und werde ich manche Lebewerte und andere Nierenwerte auch anschauen.
Ja, der guten Ordnung halber.
Und was machen Sie operativ?
Apparativ massnahmen werde ich eine Drötgernaufnahme durchverlassen.
Für diese Verkalkungen oder Konstruktionen in diesem Bereich.
Vielleicht aber Drötgernaufnahme.
Meinen Sie knöchern? Meinen Sie knöchern der Verkalkung?
Für die Verkalkung oder der Unfall, wo der verneiht.
Deshalb brauche ich keine Röntgen jetzt, aber ich brauche eine Sonografie.
Das klingt schon besser.
Und nach Kursin bei der Sonografie?
Bei der Sonografie, ich gucke die Gefäße, Perengungen und Durchblutsturungen.
Ich werde anschauen und darüber teilen, ob das in diesem Gefäße gut stürmen.
Ja, genau genommen auch der Venösefluss.
Nicht nur die Durchblutung, sondern insbesondere, weil die dicken Armen hat, der Rückfluss.
Ob es da irgendwo ein erkennbares Hindernis gibt.
Okay, ja, Ihre erste Diagnose war auch ein Blick.
Absäß, sehr sehr.
Wo sieht es auch, die Fernsehen Diagnose?
Was war Ihre Hauptdiagnose?
Absäß.
Absäß, genau.
Da würde man ja praktisch durch die Inspektion wirklich eine Stelle sehen, wo eine alte Ansammlung ist.
Wie würden Sie das behandeln?
Wenn wir eine Eiteransammlung sehen und eine Drainage durchführen dort,
dann werden wir die Drainage durchführen und wegen dieser Wärme geführt.
Aber ein Absäß wäre ja eigentlich ein ganz lokaler Schmerz, der nur an einer Stelle ist.
Die beklagt Schmerzen in ihrem ganzen rechten Arm.
Genau, ja, das ist ein bisschen anders.
Okay, jetzt sage ich erst mal als Oberärztin, untersuchen Sie mal die Patientin und berichten Sie mir nachher über die Ergebnisse.
Ansonsten sage ich jetzt, der Absäß war es nicht, sondern es war etwas anderes.
Was liegt denn noch sehr nahe?
Ja, tief wählende und auch.
Ja, das ist so etwas, wo man richtig gucken muss.
Und was Sie komplett unterschlagen haben im Bericht an Ihre Oberärztin, dass die Frau brustoperiert ist.
Das haben Sie denn nicht erzählt.
Das ist zwar 15 Jahre her oder 14 Jahre, aber das ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass die durch irgendeine blöde Geschichte einen Lymphedem entwickelt hat.
Ja, in dem operierten, auf der operierten Seite, ja, da ist eine Lymphadelectomie gelaufen.
Entweder kann das ein Zeichen sein für ein Rezediv, ja, dass die, dass die mit einmal wieder wieder was hat und dass da ein Lymphknoten, wie eine Lymphschwellung ist.
Das ist die eine Variante und die andere Variante ist eben, dass sich mehr oder weniger aus heiterem Himmel tatsächlich auch nach vielen Jahren noch ein Lymphedem bildet.
Oder aber die Geschichte, dass das Lymphedem eine Folge einer jetzt, wie gesagt, minimalen Verletzung ist.
Und wenn man sich tatsächlich irgendeine kleine Wunde hat, da reicht schon so etwas, dass man sich gekratzt hat im Garten bei der Gartenarbeit oder dass man mit einem Kartoffelschilmesser abgerutscht ist.
Oder dass man beim Fingernägel schneiden sich so ein bisschen im Nagelbett verletzt hat, ja.
Zack kriegt die eine Infektion da rein, mit einmal wird der Arm dick, die kriegt ein Erisipel in dem Arm und entwickelt ein prima Lymphedem in dem Arm, wo die voroperiert ist, ja.
Ja, also diese Spur haben sie gar nicht verfolgt, ja.
Und das wäre halt die gewesen, die es mir in diesem speziellen Fall jetzt angekommen wäre, ja.
Gut. Was wäre denn, wenn die jetzt tatsächlich eine Phlebitis oder eine Thrombose in dem Arm hat?
Dann, was würden Sie therapeutisch machen?
Okay. Eine Blutverdünnungsmedikamente, für dich, für die Abweichung, zum Beispiel niedrige Heparin.
Ja, wobei in therapeutischer Dosierung, ja.
Und für wie lange?
Abhängig von dieser Therapie-Prognose können wir mal immer benutzen oder verableichen.
Oder wie lange, ich weiß es nicht, wie lange.
Also eigentlich, bei beiden Genetrobose sagt man halbes Jahr.
Ich meine, bei Arm geht man auch von einem halben Jahr aus, wobei die natürlich nicht so lange Heparinisiert wird,
sondern dass sie dann anderweitig koaguliert wird, ja.
Er antikoaguliert wird.
Okay, und das braucht sie noch?
Für Medikamente.
Nein.
Oder?
Als Therapie.
Als Therapie für diese Thrombose, wenn sie Thrombose ist.
Als Therapie können wir Anticoagulieren auch verableichen.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Aber was machen Sie außerdem noch?
Außerden, okay.
Schmerzmittel können wir auch geben.
Keine Medikamente, ich meine das noch was anderes.
Okay, ja.
Was würden Sie bei einer Beinwählentromose machen?
Ich würde nicht kompletten.
Ja, das heißt diese Patientin geht nicht ohne einen gewickelten Arm bei Ihnen raus, ja.
So, und die kriegt eine Verordnung für einen Armstrumpf.
Damit die ihre Kompression praktisch managen kann.
Armstrumpf nach Maß, Klasse 2 und vom Handgelenk bis oben hin.
Ja.
Das sind die Grundlagen der Thrombose oder Thrombophlebitis Therapie
und natürlich Kontrolle in ein paar Tagen,
um zu gucken, wo der Thrombos hockt und ob der sich auch gelöst hat.
Ja.
Und jetzt ist noch eine wichtige Information.
Können Sie das eben mündlich sagen?
Mit dem Heparin und dem Krebs, da war eben gerade eine Information.
Da war ein Kollege, der sich gerade schriftlich gemeldet hat.
Ich bin Karrieregie, aber diese unter der Krebs wird niedrigeres Molekulär
Heparin Lebenslang empfehlen.
Jetzt momentan nicht Noac, die Gipnes Noac und ich empfehle Noac.
Noac?
Ja, ja.
Also Heparin ja immer nur für die erste Zeit, bis die anderen Medikamente an Bord sind, sozusagen.
Genau.
Und dann macht man überlappend, bis man entsprechende Gerinnungswert hat.
Okay.
Und eben eine Ultraschallkontrolle nach,
wenn man die Medikamente, die man in der Krebs,
die man in der Krebs, in der Krebs, in der Krebs, in der Krebs,
in der Krebs und eben eine Ultraschallkontrolle nach drei Tagen.
Gut.
Und bevor die ihren Strumpf irgendwann wieder ausziehen darf, nach ein halben Jahr,
muss die auch noch mal zur Kontrolle kommen.
Und dann prugt man auch noch mal nach dem Arm.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich sage mal so,
das Lymph-Edem ist mein persönliches Hobby.
Muss ich dazu sagen,
wir haben hier zehn Jahre lang in der Nähe von unserem Wohnort hier
ein kleines Krankenhaus,
in einem kleinen Krankenhaus betrieben eine Situation für Lymph-Edem-Patienten.
Und da sind tatsächlich Leute aus dem ganzen Wohnungsgebiet gekommen.
Und wir haben da konservative Lymph-Edem-Therapie gemacht.
Und deswegen finde ich diesen Fall hier so schön.
Es ist übrigens ein Fall aus Mainz.
Ja.
Und ich bin sehr begeistert,
dass sich mal jemand der Lymph-Edem-Leute angeht.
Das ist Leute.
Ja.
Gut.
Aber es kam immer die Anfrage von einer Kollegin,
die fragte, ob das Ding eindrückbar ist.
Wenn es eindrückbar gewesen wäre,
dann würde es ja mehr auf ein Lymph-Edem hindeuten.
Aber wenn es wiederkommt,
dann ist es eben ein Schläbietes oder wehentrombo.
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, das, was die Patientin ihnen am Anfang gesagt hat,
sie sind mächtig schnell mit der Sprache.
Man könnte sie ein bisschen besser verstehen,
wenn sie ein bisschen mehr Ruhe in die Sprache reintun.
Ja.
Eine witzige sprachliche Sache ist mir aufgefallen.
Das habe ich mir schnell aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar, also der Vater ist am Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Und der Bruder hatte ein Myokartinfarkt, der noch lebt.
Also nicht der Myokartinfarkt lebt noch,
sondern der Bruder lebt noch.
Also der Bruder hatte einen Myokartinfarkt,
hat den aber überlebt.
Okay, das war nur so eine kleine,
eine kleine sprachliche Geschichte.
So, was habe ich sonst?
Ne, sonst habe ich mir nichts weiter aufgeschrieben.
Also wie gesagt, ein bisschen...
Langsamer aufdeutet.
Langsamer, dann ist es leichter verständlich.
Und ja, was eben wichtig gewesen wäre,
dass sie diese Brust-OP auf alle Fälle mit ihren Bericht reinnehmen.
Das ist nichts, was man so vernachlässigen kann.
Zumal die Schwester ja auch noch erkrankt ist.
Also das ist schon eine sehr, sehr wichtige Diagnose
in dem Zusammenhang.
Und da hätte ich mir eigentlich auch gewünscht,
dass sie dabei der Patientin noch ein bisschen mehr nachfragen.
Dass sie sagen, was weiß ich,
beschwerde frei regelmäßige geneupologische Untersuchungen
nach Sorge, Pipapo.
Das wäre schon ganz gut gewesen.